-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night.
We hope everybody
is doing well tonight.
And now let's get to the news.
Russian President Vladimir Putin
yesterday
ordered troops into separatist
regions of eastern Ukraine
and said they were
"peacekeepers."
Specifically,
they're keeping this piece.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden is set
to impose sanctions
after Putin ordered troops
into Ukraine.
From now on, Russia doesn't
get the new Wordle until noon.
[ Laughter ]
It's very easy.
Russian Wordle's very easy,
'cause it's always "Putin."
[ Laughter ]
Senate Judiciary chair
Dick Durbin said yesterday
that his first call
when Supreme Court justice
Stephen Breyer
announced his retirement
was to his committee's
top Republican, Chuck Grassley.
And Grassley's first call
was to,
I don't know,
Alexander Graham Bell?
[ Laughter ]
According to the latest numbers,
more than half of unemployed
American men in their 30s
have criminal records.
Also vinyl ones.
[ Laughter ]
The social-media platform
Snapchat
unveiled a new feature last week
that allows users to share their
real-time location with friends.
You can learn more about it
in an upcoming episode
of "Dateline."
[ Laughter ]
"Snapchat wasn't the only thing
that disappeared that day."
[ Laughter ]
A passable Keith Morrison.
According to a new survey,
59% of Americans prefer
for toilet paper to be hung
so that the next sheet
comes from over the roll.
And somehow that 59% are all
married to the other 41%.
[ Laughter ]
"The New York Times" published
an op-ed yesterday titled
"Ignoring a Text Message
or E-mail Isn't Always Rude.
Sometimes It's Necessary."
And I think I speak for everyone
when I say, "K."
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to a new survey,
40% of Americans said that they
don't enjoy gossiping at all
and then added,
"But you know who does?
Jessica, Jessica."
[ Laughter ]
And, oh, that's some
really good gossip.
Look at them.
[ Laughter ]
If somebody is whispering
in your ear,
you can't make that face.
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "I have a secret."
It's like...
Like, you can't do that
at a barbecue.
And then everyone's like, "What
were you guys talking about?"
"Um, the potato salad."